toute ma vie, je le regarderais en
costume d'arène, vous pourriez prendre un homme adulte d'
une main Aramis Festus est un pro et il
m'a dit qu'il devait ordonner de porter le
manteau de Panda, il me le passerait
et serait juste roi, a-t-il dit  moi, il était trop
gros pour porter le costume je lui ai dit de ne pas
parler non plus il m'a appris à ne pas faire
confiance au monde extérieur pourquoi a-t-il
changé d'avis le
temps il a une façon de vous faire
revenir sur les choses que vous avez faites
faites  vous avez déjà regardé en arrière votre temps en tant que
chien de guerre, sachez simplement que le monde extérieur est
trop imprévisible pour un vieil homme comme moi
vous